The first issue is configuration.
It may not be apparent from the discussion so
far that components are typically configurable.
What this means is that the component vendor provides a means,
such as a configuration file,
by which the client using a component can tailor it to a particular situation.
This gives to the designer a powerful means for managing design trade-offs.
For example, space versus time.
This flexibility that configuration gives comes at a cost, however.
Because configuration is a form of late binding, it becomes difficult to
unit test the components in the actual usage environment.
It is also more expensive to document and to deploy them.